How to create an App with no money?
So I got a great question from my YouTube viewers
(love you guys!)
PANTYHOSEPAM
who wrote in to say
“Hello Evan, I have a real multimillion pound app
unfortunately just an idea and it is unique at the moment
such an app hasn’t been released yet.
The problem is I can’t write the code for it
and I can’t pay all the code writers for the job.
What would you suggest? Thank you, Pam.”
Great question and
usually when I make these videos
I give 3 suggestions for what you can do.
For you, I really just have one
and that’s partner up.
Find somebody
who loves programming
just as much as you love creating
and marketing stuff
and
work together.
Because if you don’t have the funds
to hire somebody on board
then the best bet is to have somebody on your team
who’s just as committed to this as you.
It’s hard to run a technology company
when you don’t have a
technology person in the business
because there’s going to be
so many issues that come up
where you need technical expertise
and if you can’t afford to hire somebody
then you have to have somebody
who’s a partner in the business.
And it’s also great because you have somebody
who’s committed to it just like you are, right
If something crashes at 3 in the morning
your employee’s not going to wake up and go to work
but your partner is
and so it’s finding that right person.
What you need to do is
figure out what your skill sets are.
And so if you want to do the marketing
the promotion, the branding of it
that’s what you’re really good at
and you have this awesome idea for an app
you want the people who love making apps
who’ve created great apps
and I get people writing to me all the time
“I’ve created this great app
but I don’t know how to market it
and I don’t know how to brand it
I don’t know how to promote it
and get the word to spread about.
All I want to do is create apps.”
That’s who you need to partner with.
So I would go out
and find people in the industry, right
whatever industry you’re trying to target
if it’s healthcare or sports or children
or whatever it is
find people who’ve created apps in that industry
that are great app developers
but haven’t done a great job marketing
and partner up with them and say
“Hey, I have this great idea for an app.
Let’s split it. Let’s work together on this.
You code it. I’ve got this great idea
and I will go out there and market it
and together we can build a great team.”
That’s who you need to find,
so partner up.
Believe.
For those of you watching you like the video
you can support me
by clicking on the link in the description
that’s what helps keep these videos going.
You can comment
let me know what you think.
Leave a comment below and click on my face
subscribe to the channel.
Thank you so much, I’ll see you soon.